derrière les portes de l'église
saint-martin de toucher une offrande qui
intrigue
ce tableau la facture est ancienne le
thème religieux des bras anonymes ont
déposé ici discrètement madame le maire
se fait tant qu' trice pour élucider ce
qu'elle appelle une sacrée surprise
tombé du ciel
on nous a déposé sa ce magnifique
tableau et pourquoi
d'où vient-il qui a fait ce don est ce
quelqu'un de la commune est ce quelqu'un
qui a des attaches avec la commune est
ce quelqu'un qui aime particulièrement
cette commune alors ça sont tous les
points positifs et on peut se poser
d'autres questions est ce que c'est un
objet volé
l'enquêté piétine le doute ne se dissipe
pas où on voit très bien la marque d'un
d'un entourage qu'il était en haut et en
bas
ce tableau n'est pas signé deux mètres
de haut et plus d'un mètre de large
il suggère la représentation de mari
porté au ciel par des anges mais il
pourrait également incarner le visage de
la pécheresse parthenay marie madeleine
son regard extatique en dit long si
d'aventuré nous avons la certitude que
ce tableau nous est destinée que c'est
bien un cadeau pour la commune nous
ferons réaliser une expertise bien
évidemment sa destination sera tout
simple sera installé quelque part dans
l'église sur les conseils de la drague
dont nous nous entourons bien évidemment
pour qu'ils soient en meilleure place
possible parce qu'il restera toujours
dans notre coeur si c'est un cadeau si
c'est un don c'est bienveillant donc ça
aura beaucoup d'importance pour nous on
lui trouvera une place de choix bien
évidemment la mairie espère que le
donateur anonyme à se manifester et
permettre de lever tous les doutes
les cloches de saint martin pourront
peut-être porté au loin
cet espoir